vous rendez compte quand même qu'en
termes de méthode on a un petit sujet en
jeu bien qu'olivier ferrand nous nous
fasse des des mamours depuis quelques
semaines en me disant vous allez voir on
voit qu'au coût construire discuter nous
n'avons pas le texte aujourd'hui faut
que nos auditeurs le comprennent on
découvre tous les jours dans la presse
le texte si on veut qu construire comme
les allemands puisqu'on en parle
beaucoup il faudrait que nous ayons le
texte si on veut rentrer dans une
nouvelle version de notre démocratie
parlementaire le texte nous devrions
l'avoir construit ensemble avant le
conseil des ministres puisque c'est au
moment du conseil des ministres que le
coup est parti si vous permettez cette
expression et c'est pour la raison pour
laquelle d'ailleurs depuis déjà une
semaine où les républicains nous avons
adressé au gouvernement une série de
propositions sur les carburants sur la
baisse de la csg sur la baie conjugale
isation de l'allocation adulte handicapé
par exemple qui fait partie aussi pour
nous des mesures de pouvoir d'achat
fondamentales et de dignité de justice
sociale une certaine incidence de
mesures en disant gouvernement sur ce
sujet nous sommes prêts à vous suivant
je n'ai pas le sentiment que le
gouvernement ait lu les documents que
nous lui avons envoyés et le petit
manège d'olivier ferrand qui consiste à
dire moi je suis là pour discuter pour
dialoguer pour co-construire enfin c'est
ça
circulez ya rien à voir pardonnez moi
mais c'est pas comme ça que les choses
vont avancer